So a
what,
what triggers a panic attack is,
hm,
I'm hesitating because there's sort of
two main models of this.
I mean,
one is that I guess the both of them
center on the idea that,
um,
that everyone is capable of having a
panic attack you for it.
If a tiger suddenly ran into the room,
you would probably have a tie,
a panic attack.
And so that means that we have the brain
circuitry to have a panic attack.
And the idea is that that,
that the,
that the circuitry is meant to be
triggered by actual immediate danger.
And people who have clinical panic
attacks have those attacks without,
you know,
when there is no real danger.
And so what we think is that this,
the,
the trigger is,
um,
it is more easily set off so to speak.
Now,
what sets it off?
Um,
it,
it can almost be like a loose wire.
You could think of it as a loose wire in
your fire alarm system or something.
So it can,
sometimes it can just just set off.
But,
um,
a lot of times there's a lot of evidence
that what triggers a panic attack is a,
an actual bodily sensation of the sort
that you have when you have anxiety.
So if you think about adrenaline rush,
you have heart palpitations,
you get a little short of breath,
you feel a little shaky,
sweaty,
any of those kinds of feelings,
um,
can trigger it kind of,
what we call catastrophic
misinterpretations on the part of the
person who's prone to having panic
attacks.
So that there,
what we know about such people is that
they're
more sensitive than the rest of us to
the bodily sensations to start with.
So if,
you know,
if you had,
for example,
panic attacks,
you would be better able to tell me
right now what your heart rate is.
Then I would be able to tell you.
And so there's that sensitivity start
with,
and then then something starts your
heart racing.
And that could be running up a flight of
stairs.
It could be I'm drinking a cup of
coffee.
It could be getting mad at someone,
you know,
any of those kinds of things.
Your heart starts to race and all of a
sudden you sense that pretty early on
when it starts to beat faster and all of
a sudden you are feeling it and you
think your mind automatically thinks
something terrible's happening.
Something very dangerous is happening
within your body.
You might be having,
he might think you're having a heart
attack or a stroke or some such thing.
And so that is frightening in itself.
Right?
So then that triggers more fear,
more bodily sensations in your
continuing.
Sure.
I mean,
that's,
you know,
I think that,
that the treatments that we do that have
been proven to be helpful for people
center on kind of desensitize.
It's almost like you have a phobia of
your own bodily sensations.
So you know how we work with phobias.
If you were afraid of cats,
I'm someone who's afraid of cats.
We put them in front of cats,
right?
So that they essentially learn.
The cats really aren't that dangerous.
And um,
and so we follow that same principle
with panic attacks and we evoke bodily
sensations.
So,
in,
you know,
we might have someone run in place in
the office and their heart starts to
race and then they see that they're,
yeah,
that's a normal reaction to running in
place.
And,
you know,
we're,
we're sort of there with them and
helping them with that and we basically
desensitize them and,
and you know,
and teach them also what is behind a
panic attack?
Well,
you know,
um,
that's,
that's a question that's,
that's a very good question because
that's what we're grappling with right
this minute in the new diagnostic system
that's being,
you know,
the,
every so often we rewrite the
psychiatric diagnostic system.
And so one of the big questions is,
you know,
should we be looking at anxiety and mood
and,
um,
other kinds of psychological problems on
a dimensional scale like that.
And,
um,
and if so,
where's the cutoff?
You know,
and,
and so it's probably not just in one
place.
Now the skills that I've developed,
where are ones that are focused very
much so on diagnoses that we already
make.
And so there,
um,
the cutoff is,
is based basically determined by when we
can diagnose panic disorder for example,
of the panic disorder severity scale.
We can say that,
you know,
I can tell you a number,
but you know,
there's a number that corresponds to the
best,
um,
kind of indicator that someone will have
a diagnosis of panic disorder.
So that's how we do that.
But,
you know,
but there is the,
it's absolutely true that there's a
dimension,
you know,
these symptoms occur in a dimensional
way such that,
um,
there certainly there's normal anxiety
and um,
and there's normal panic even,
even though so panics different from
anxiety because panic is an immediate
fear reaction,
right?
Whereas anxiety is more something we
think is going to happen in the future.
So panic occurs when you think,
like I said before,
if there's a tiger in the room,
someone's pointing a gun at you,
it's something that looks like it's the
future,
but it's the immediate future as opposed
to,
you know,
I'm anxious about a test I'm going to
have to take next week or something.